given this thing's reputation I don't
know how much fury I'm just gonna bring
down myself for saying this but it's not
that bad the twin dilemma Doctor Who
classic review times spoiler warning
upfront because I am gonna be talking
about how the whole thing goes but given
that this is not particularly well
regarded episode I suspect a lot of
people are not gonna worry about being
spoiled for it anyway so this is Colin
Baker's first time out as the doctor
following the regeneration coming off of
the caves of Androzani one of the best
regarded episodes of classic Doctor Who
and this thing has an atrocious
reputation you often find it in the
upper echelons of top 10 worst episodes
of classic Doctor Who if not of all time
of Doctor Who it keeps showing up over
and over and over again on those lists
and I watched it and I went I don't get
the what's the opposite of hype I don't
get the reverse hype so now let me be
emphatic about this it's not good but I
don't look guys maybe I'm just not
completely tuned in to classic who fans
yet because the stuff that I see wrong
with this and there's plenty and I'll
get to it is all stuff that I've had
classic who fans tell me I'm a killjoy
or or I just don't get it when I
complain about these same things in
other episodes the bad costume designed
the poor creature design choices the
wonky wobbly sets very mixed bag acting
from the guest stars like I complained
about this stuff in other episodes and I
have been told basically oh I just don't
get it and yet all that stuff is present
here and somehow nobody likes this one I
don't know maybe there's a line that
gets crossed in this one and I just
don't know where the heck that line is
but I'm sitting I'm sitting here
watching this just going okay this stuff
is not any worse than I'm like look
here's an episode that I've seen that is
worse than this that's the power of
Kroll now the
power of kroll which was a fourth doctor
episode that has a lot of the same stuff
bad designs on the aliens the stand you
know the sets are literally wobbling
when they get brushed against the
performances by the by the guest stars
are not necessarily bad performances but
they're not helping they're not adding
anything to it but that is a genuinely
bad episode and this I would say is
better than that if for no other reason
than the power of Kroll doesn't have a
story I mean its story is so simplistic
it doesn't need to be told really at all
certainly not over multiple parts this
story is a pretty standard Doctor Who
story of the era and it's got the kind
of you know space sci-fi concepts and
ideas that Doctor Who is good for and is
known for and they're about as sound as
most other stuff so given that it has
that and all the other stuff is stuff
that again I don't necessarily like and
isn't good but I've seen defended in
other episodes I just don't see why so
much hate gets piled on to this one now
having done a weird sort of not quite
defending it defending it
let's talk about what actually doesn't
work cuz there's plenty I mentioned the
wobbly sets I try not to bring up wobbly
sets too much because I understand that
it was they were on a tight budget it
was something that happened but for
crying out loud
when you have a panel that a character
it's not just a background piece that
character has to interact with it and it
wobble it shakes back and forth every
time it so much as gets bumped just put
a shim under the thing level it out
really really no but like just somewhere
in a back Union closet somewhere there
wasn't just a little shimmer wood to
level the friggin thing no no I don't
believe that that that's not what that's
not wobbly sets because you have no
budget that's wobbly sets because
somebody or multiple people even are
going screw it that'll do and that I'm
sorry you don't get a pass for that I'll
excuse limited budget I won't excuse
apathy and that's the only thing that I
can
for how long li some of this stuff is in
terms of designs by the the villain I
think suffers the works from this with
Mester who's this sort of big slug thing
and the design it's not the worst design
for a villain creature that I've seen in
Doctor Who but I think this this is kind
of what I was talking about when I've
complained about things like how the
matrix appeared in the deadly assassin
and things like this it's it's not that
it's poorly executed for what the idea
is the idea is flawed at the ins at the
inception level because this is your
main villain more to the point he starts
appearing episode 1 he's not like a
reveal villain and you get him later
you're dealing with him pretty much
immediately and the guy the guy can't
perform behind that mask but you can see
his jaw vaguely moving but he's got this
loft locked off mask thing I don't know
if maybe the theory was well we get away
with it with the Cybermen but the
Cybermen are robotic I mean they're not
actually robots cuz you know augmented
humans and all that but that they're
robotic they're metallic you can have
that this is supposed to be an organic
being when it's this locked off mask
with just this chin waggling a little
bit at the bottom no you don't get away
with it especially cuz it muffles the
performance on I don't just mean the
words like I feel really bad for the
actor cuz he's trying you can hear it in
his in his performance he is working so
hard to give a performance through this
mask and I think honestly he doesn't
bite as well as he could have done but
if they just put him in anything other
than that he probably would have been a
kind of compelling villain but he just
looks ridiculous and the camera keeps
lingering on this face that doesn't move
so that's what I talk about when I
complain about the designs not the final
execution of how it turned out because
you know sometimes it works sometimes it
doesn't but like that idea how did
nobody realized boy this is our main
villain who were gonna be seeing a lot
of maybe he should be able to emot-- a
little better than this and nobody
thought that again screw it that'll
do so that's sort that's my issue with
that I mentioned mixed bag acting from
the supporting cast and actually that
isn't that bad either i mean the twins
are a little annoying but they're not
awful they're not as bad as Adric was
and america they're very much in the
same mold as agile now that i actually
stop and think about it
that some of the other characters the
the jacquard Ian's the sort of bird ish
people that find that design you know it
it looks ridiculous but it's that I mean
that I'll roll with that way better than
the slug guy because I look at them and
go okay that looks ridiculous but it
also looks not human they can give a
performance they can you can see them
move you can see them a moat cool it can
be saved by decent performance and
they're fine they're functional um as
male the the Time Lord or Edgeworth he
pretends to be who the doctor encounters
there he's actually quite good he's
actually a really good supporting
character and I like for comparison for
the last one I did hey way better
Castellon I mean that guy good he was
dead weight this guy isn't he actually
even has a fairly moving performance
part towards the end as the character is
dying so I mean he works really well but
I've been kind of dancing around the
elephant in the room to a certain degree
haven't I in it and that's Colin Baker
is Colin Baker good in this no but this
is literally the one kind of story that
I will give a free pass to the
performance of the doctor on it's the
post regeneration story the doctors
always wonky poster generation now is
this worse than other times well yeah in
a lot of ways on a lot of levels but we
kind of also had a heads up I mean as
Peter Davison bright before regeneration
he said something like something's off
something's wrong I forget the exact
line somebody will will tell me in the
comments I'm sure cuz they always do so
you know we got this heads up that
things are gonna be weird and off and
especially with that is the lead-in I
it's one of those things that like in
hindsight knowing how he would continue
to play the doctor
overall you can look at this episode and
go man there's all the things that are
gonna be wrong throughout his run on the
show at least as I said I'm starting to
get into Big Finish and he's better
there but that that's hindsight like if
I had watched this at the time it aired
I probably would have gone on boy I'm
really worried about the doctor I'll
wait and see though because you know you
give him a freebie on the first one I
mean Peter Davison played the doctor
really weird and funky and not very
representative at all at how of how he
was gonna continue to play the character
in Castroville bus so you know like I
said Colin Baker is not good well the
conception of what they're doing with
the doctor I don't want to say Colin
Baker is not good I think Colin Baker is
doing what he was asked to do but it was
it was the wrong approach so is it
working no it's definitely not but I
again I feel like it's it's hindsight
it's like it's the kickoff to an era
that everybody hates and so people just
love to pile on this episode and again
guys it's just it's not that bad I mean
as bad as the slugs look as far as the
plan to basically blow up with a planet
that they're on and so that they're
super heat-resistant eggs just spread
out and land on planets and then
incubate that's a decent enough threat
the whole idea of trying to fix the
planet by getting other planets to orbit
it and fix it its orbit and getting you
know synchronization going and to have
them be out of time like that's a nifty
sci-fi solution to the situation there
and and even the whole thing with like
Mester like getting into the guys mind
which is weird since when can slugs do
that that's a very tacked on villain
ability but whatever let's go with it
like that and the whole way he's
defeated that's very Doctor Who - so um
you like the ideas are sound it's just
yeah like I said like I said it's not
good I just don't understand why it gets
piled on as much as it is and coming
back to call him Baker so I think the
thing is and the reason he doesn't work
even in isolation really in this episode
although like I said if I
watching at the time I would have given
him a pass on this occasion probably
only this occasion but um you know
you're you're watching it and the thing
is he keeps flipping back and forth and
you get early on that he's basically in
a manic state just flip-flopping back
and forth back and forth back and forth
but the thing is he never seems to
settle on anything that's Pleasant
it's basically a question of is he
completely out of character
ie cowardly violent or is he just
insufferably smug because that's like
the best he comes off and I think the
most telling thing is that he doesn't
want to help anybody like he wants to
save peri maybe once after he abandoned
her and again I get he's flipping back
and forth but at at almost no point in
any of his shifting about and his kind
of ravings is he being a good person
like that that's not even and that's not
even a flicker like he has to be
convinced by peri to not let this guy
who just survived a ship crash die she
she had to basically strong-arm him into
saving somebody's life and if you're
gonna have the doctor go arrogant
especially you know with five
incarnations of a to varying degrees
benevolent caring doctor to then do this
it's not it's not like you're shifting
his personality it's like you're
ignoring everything that came before
with that kind of you know
representation and persona and the
doctor if he the doctor can save people
and be snarky about it be grumpy about
it seem annoyed by it but he should want
to help he shouldn't need to be talked
into having to help not this far in
anyways like the only doctor that that
I'd be okay with that being the case is
Hartnell like way back then fine early
days he needs to be talked into action
sometimes in this no no but again you
know first
I still would have given a past that I
think maybe with one exception there's
one moment that I think was really
ill-advised so the very end of the
episode the doctor says to Perry you
know I'm the doctor whether you like it
or not he might as well have turned to
the camera and said hey audience I don't
care if you missed the old guy you got
me now suck it up I mean like how
confrontational like that's and again I
think it just speaks to the
wrongheadedness of the whole era and I
don't want to put that on Baker himself
there was a lot of just the mentality of
the of that era just wasn't working and
I think that line basically exemplifies
it because when we have a new doctor and
the doctor generates what should happen
is the doctor the new performance the
new actor should be showing us why we
can love this doctor too
not telling us that we're stuck with him
and we better love him not like that
that's just being a jerk that's the
character Beezer that's the show
being a jerk to its fans my god imagine
if Jodie Whitaker's first episode ended
with her saying I'm the doctor whether
you like it or not people would lose
their minds in the worst way if she did
that but they friggin did it I think
that's about all I've got on this like I
said it's not good but I don't get why
it's put in like worst episode of all
time category in most areas it's not any
worse than any other episodes that I've
seen much better regarded than this
maybe it's just the confluence of how
many things aren't working I don't know
it's but it's just it's a classic who
episode that I watched that I won't ever
watch again but wasn't painful and I was
kind of expecting it to be I'm almost
slightly disappointed on that measure so
yeah that's the twin dilemma have you
seen this thing what did you think about
it what is so awful about it that I'm
not getting whatever your thoughts are
drop something down to comments let's
talk about it do all the stuff
likes and subscribes I got Twitter and
podcast and a painter Ellen if you give
the generous type links for all that
stuff is down below and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]